how's it going at the voice does it fun
this season it's uh it's weird for me
it's weird talking to you like I feel
like I'm cheating on you or something no
I'm so excited I was so excited I mean
announced uh Camila because I I was like
well way to fill like the same kind of
personality I was gonna say she has the
same mentality as you like she doesn't
care about Glam or about what she wears
like she's just kind of like a she's
just talks a lot and she's competitive
and she's um she's used yeah I was like
when she came on the show I was like I'm
so excited for her to go against Blake
yeah and it actually it was crazy
because like the first few days I felt
like it took her like a couple days to
really get there and after the first
shut up Blake then it was on it was like
finally she goes shut up Blake and then
it was like this whole like they're open
yeah it's a really great moment
yeah shut up Blake yeah it really does
um so do you ever feel like you're
coaching I always feel like because
we're moms as well do you ever feel like
you're kind of the mama you feel like
very maternal with your children I do
for me honestly and I know that you year
like this and I'm not sure Blake is
because Blake isn't but when I coach
when I'm actually in those like reality
days when we get to really work with
them yeah that's like my favorite part
like besides Glam obviously yeah my
favorite part but I love being in there
and watching them grow like right before
my eyes and it sometimes these are the
young ones like Carter yeah and
sometimes it's like you think you're
gonna say something like why don't you
try this and you you're doing that
because you have the knowledge from all
the year I do from all those years and I
look back and it's really fun for me to
go try this and then they do it and you
think in your mind it's not going to do
anything and then it does yeah and not
even just me but the whole room is like
oh my gosh like that he came to life
like right before our eyes so it's
sometimes you have to instill that
confidence yeah yeah it's in a really
incredible show and um I love doing it
so much I'm so happy to be back yeah
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]